[Music]
they are buying like can we talk about
what they bought they've come on the pod
before
uh and they're pretty public about stuff
so they're buying companies like
cool pool construction companies so it's
like
uh you know pools are this like amazing
business that you could you could do and
they bought one and like i think it's
called dolphin pools or something like
that they bought it in arizona it
crushes it
they hired this one operator who's like
really good who took it over from the
original owner the boomer owner and
basically
it's grown like crazy and that's like
one of their cash cows now
and i uh and they also bought a internet
web like um i got in the country like
they don't have like a t or time warner
or whatever they they have like local
providers and they bought one of those
and it's doing well and i have family
members so my dad is an entrepreneur
like five as kids they bought five
different yeah a bunch of internet
service providers
and they're all doing i think pretty
good um and so my dad owns a small
business that none of his family is
taking over my father-in-law owns a
small business who
and it is really it's a killer business
i mean um and they uh he somehow the uh
our new brother-in-law is now gonna take
it over and
seeing the turmoil that he had to go
through in order to he was like well i
spent 40 years building this thing and i
guess if no one that i love wants it i'm
just going to shut it down
and it was like kind of tragic
and it's like i'm literally willing to
give this to a family member and they
can make many millions of dollars a year
if they wanted to do this it's just it's
free you could have it and
people didn't want to do it
and so i've seen this process and it is
like an emotional
it's it's a really is it's a huge
challenge and this is very a very
interesting market there's some stats
about how many do you know how many
boomers are retiring and like that's
like some absurd number
it's absurd it's like it's like it's
like a quarter of the country like or or
a third of the country biggest wealth
transfers of all time is about to happen
it's the like that that group of people
when they pass down their hair
it's gonna it's like many trillions of
dollars i think i don't know if that's
that might be hyperbole but i think it's
something like that some ridiculous
number
and then that's like a lot of people
that are just not gonna have to work but
also don't know what to do with it and
similarly there's many many businesses
that was when enduring first pitched it
they were like
they just showed me the stats they're
like there are this many boomer
businesses where they want to retire
they don't want to run their business
anymore and their kids don't want to
take it over and like those businesses
are up for grabs and they're like too
small like they're not sexy as a startup
and they're too small for big private
equity and so we're going to be like
basically like permanent equity where
they're going to be
they're just going to buy it and hold
these amazing businesses for a very long
time and they keep doing that one after
another uh like i think sieve and xavier
they've rolled up like
almost 100 million dollars of business
equity
off of a two million dollar starting
equity amount like we
[Laughter]
it is crazy i i invested in what i
didn't have a lot of money when i first
invested in so but at the time it was
like 10 or 15 000 or something like that
that i invested it was like that was a
big deal
it's just been like it's just been
growing and growing and growing no so
they so they were like they're like sean
like you've helped us like think through
this idea and like they do like i like
this stuff i'll be helpful along the way
so they're like you know we want to
offer you like if you invest we'll also
offer you like an inves an advisor or
like like an advisory grant that'll just
match your investment and uh
and i think they thought i was gonna do
like you forgot to file the paperwork no
no no i think they thought i was gonna
put in like 25k or like max or like 20k
something like that so they're like okay
cool you got like 20k of equity we'll
give you 20k worth of advisory shares
but i was like a big believer in what
they were doing so i put in 200 000
and then they were like they're like oh
and i was like look you don't have to
like i get it you don't have to give me
200 000 of advisor shares but xavier was
like nope a deal's a deal and um like i
was like we didn't sign anything and
like dude i'm totally okay with it but
he's like no like
like we will we'll honor that and also
like i know you'll like you'll deliver
and so since then i've had this like
immense desire to deliver on that it was
actually the best thing he ever did
because he got me to basically work for
him for free uh for this one like for
this act of goodwill i am like i will i
see your goodwill and i raise you ten
times goodwill on my own side it's gonna
that's gonna end up being a great one of
your better investments i would think
depending on i don't know when you got
in if were you with very we both were
you both yes then that's gonna i think
it's gonna crash exactly like i think
already let's say conservatively that's
probably up
20x you know like something like that in
valuation you think that's up 20x
because if they go raise now they
basically have i don't know exact
numbers but like
somewhere between
25 to 50 million of
revenue
closer to 50 million in revenue from
these businesses now
um that they've acquired off of 2
million
[Music]
you